hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar planning
to succeed
how and where standardization can
improve your microbiome studies
am alexis krause of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labberts
and brought to you by maui dna
technologies
to learn more please visit their website
at maui dna dot com
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into ask a question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation you can
also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
i'd like to now welcome both of our
speakers dr julia cope
director of scientific operation and
quality at cosmos id
and dr bassam alpha maui ceo
and cto of maui dna technologies
dr elfa maui welcome you may now begin
your presentation
um thank you it's a pleasure to be on
this webinar and
alongside dr julia from cosmo's id um
uh you know just we want to walk you
through what maui does at early
on in the in the first part of the
presentation and how we
help in empowering medical discoveries
through sample collection
um we uh
basically we are uh the area-based
company
um usa made technology uh we started
late in 2014.
um uh our major focus
of course uh focus of our product a
product
offering our technology is a sample
stabilization so the way we
um you know we developed it it really
came out of
hard work not very long nine years of
dedication
in terms of pre-development and
optimization
um our objective is to help in resolving
the jigsaw um
of of understanding health and wellness
and we believe
you know to understand the bigger
picture
you need to look at dna you know
basically cell morphology
rna expression proteomics metabolites
and microbiome potentially and because
of that
we wanted to enable um
looking into that if possibly from the
same sample
our objective with our technologies is
to get to have it
being universal and universal entails in
two in three different categories
you can get the sample from anyone you
can
potentially get more analyte out of the
sample you collect it
and uh it's room temperature so
basically
room temperature is stable so it provide
accessible
at a global scale so you don't have to
have cold chain involved
um so we have different sample types
that we deal with depending on the
chemistry
we we we enable on our device
which is the i swab i'll come to it in a
bit
um also we are actually getting whole
blood tubes
uh being launched soon and stabilization
all of them uh going towards the the
concept which which is omix
which is basically taking multiple
analytes from the same sample rather
than
getting it from different types of
samples
so go back you know just to describe to
you
go back to the concept of universal
enabling global access
so first we came up with the concept of
um
you know collecting from of course swaps
is the least invasive aspect of things
and
swaps is readily available almost in
every
you know bathroom cabinet or you know
like q-tips
um and you know the medical
staff forensics specialist
use swaps on a daily basis and they know
how to use it the problem with the swap
is basically you don't get a high
quality sample everybody knows that
when you get it to the lab you have to
have quite a bit of time
for pre-processing time to get
the swell processed and always it is one
swap per sample
um so our concept is basically we have a
squeeze
a squeegee inside i would call it a
squeegee we call it insert
inside our tube our device it's a two ml
self-standing tube it's very very
convenient very small basically
the insert has three three legs those
three legs have horizontal
tiny teeth that bite into the surface
area
of the swab head when you get it inside
the tube
so it is a mechanistic release of the
swap
and then depending on the analyte you
are looking for
the sample change like the property
stabilizing buffer in there
we can we actually offer it in different
capabilities so that mechanistic
uh capability allows someone uh
to collect more than one swap also
and concentrated more than swap per
individual if somebody wants to do
pooling they can do that as well
in a limited amount of volume so
it's truly you know collect concentrate
stabilize
all in the same tube and the nice thing
about it
we not just made it simple to collect we
made it simple to process when you get
to the lab there is no swap
to deal with and there is the sample is
stabilized
at the point of collection so you're not
worried about degradation or any aspect
of that
um just to not name few of the
applications that we
we actually the iswab is being used in
so whether it is genomics testing
genomic
testing or pharmacogenomics or cancer
research
requiring surrogate
cells which is basically uh epithelial
cells
or if it's a crime scene you're
collecting a a trouble blood somewhere
or you know
trying to collect the dna from a
fingerprint leftover or
blood drops you know uh animal uh
either oral or nasal and
of course fecal which is the topic of
this
seminar that we're going to talk about
our experience
working with cosmos id on that so it is
simple four steps just collect
and basically release uh
inside get the the the swab inside the
tube and the mechanistic approach
basically the
mechanistic squeegee inside will remove
everything off the swab head
and then it's stabilizing the buffer and
there that is
dispensed in the in the system in the
tube and
eventually if you get it as a kit you
just put it in an envelope follow
instructions send it to that
as simple as that it's room temperature
you can
you know uh we designed our box kit box
to be usbs
compatible it's white box or
or you can use your own um
it goes either way um
so briefly um we talked you know i i
keep
bringing universal sample collection
versus sample collection
simply if we put it in perspective here
just to summarize it's suitable for all
population segments
uh newborns to you know
whatever age it is and forensics people
use it on
corpse more family members can be and
the concept of of being universal and
cover more population is more familiar
members can be included in the cohort
studies which gives
again a multi-generation
look at the genetic profile it is
room temperature stable so
when we say for invasive non-invasive it
depends on if you're collecting blood
drops or you're collecting blood draws
this is also a part of of the products
that
that we can help uh uh stabilize
oral blood tissue cells animal feces
soil
urine vagina skin which is our i swab
microbiome
uh the topic we talked we're talking
about the focus of the topic
our major objective think of a flower
um that's freshly picked
you know we basically your sample will
be maintained in that
level until you process it so you get
the full the full picture almost like it
has been taken
minutes ago without worrying about you
know
a backlog in the lab or delays in
processing samples where you know others
others even you know with free star
cycles it affects the
sample quality um
one uh thing that i missed explaining
earlier about universal also
our objective also to have the the
the device or the technology being
uh capable or
enabling uh lab processing on different
platforms
and we do not we don't have a special
chemistry to extract dna from our
our system or a special chemistry to to
extract
microbial dna or microbot microbial rna
from our system
it's literally what is in the market
this is our objective we don't want
uh our customers to deviate
in terms of how to basically
incur more cost to optimize and get
use a different chemistry for
specifically for our samples literally
for our dna i swap dna
if you are using blood extraction method
whether
you know whatever is from the provider i
show here whether it's promega
beckman cool sir banker berken l mark
imagine or
or omega unfortunately i don't have
omega on here or
mac bio i don't have mac bio here as
well
but there is a long list of validated
chemistries
you basically use the blood extraction
with our system so if you are a lab
you're getting blood samples
and and let's say oral samples you do
not have to switch
platforms or chemistries also
the dna comes out of it is compatible
with
uh different genomic uh assay um i say
assays as well as different platforms
processing platforms whether it is gene
expression
genotyping or uh single sequencing or
next generation sequencing
uh and that involves dnac and rnas
dna sequencing and rna sequencing
economy seek as well
16s or meta genomic so or shotgun
approach
all these oh actually if it is
you know this is one of the values of of
it's being used in forensics
for example eyeswap id
it's a single swap collection for for
reference samples or sorry reference
samples or
uh just evidentiary samples you can
actually
use it without the need of extraction
it's it's compatible with
svr profiling platforms uh promega and
thermo
uh among of those that has been
validated on that
as a company as a startup we still
consider ourselves a startup
company um we're very vigilant in terms
of responding to different
uh you know different scenarios and in
the industry so what happens
now we responded to the pandemic in
different ways
so we actually developed we have islam
microbiome
in our mind we never thought that we
would use it in a pandemic but we
developed it in a way that can
cover different microbial entities and
different sample types so why not
of course and it has been used quite a
bit
we looked and it is the only non-toxic
sample stabilization technology
um i can elaborate later uh if uh on
why it is non-toxic um
so basically you know
essentially uh we sold millions samples
of we actually uh
samples of of those uh for for
coronavirus testing coveted 19.
um but the bottom line i go back to the
extraction
so the the performance of the
of the ice swap microbiome originally it
was you
it is and still being used for fetal
sample collection and
one of our major objectives this data
i'm showing here i apologize
it's a lot but it's just to show
uh whether you use mac track power soil
or zymo
extraction all of them works equally the
same
and gives the same output unlike other
system out there which actually make
our iso of microbiome more of a gold
standard
for microbial sample collection which
actually has been
called out in uh in a 10 000 family
study
a proof of concept where actually they
came out and said
it is fast and easy this is the
participant so basically we're talking
about compliance
uh it came anonymously chosen by
volunteers
as most um
everything in one so samples are are uh
you know they don't know it to freeze
them
the form is small so it's easy to
transport and store
so you can collect a store more samples
and the method is cost efficient you
know this is you know our sales our
marketing would love to have to say that
so
uh and actually the customers felt it
uh part so i i'm gonna jump jump a
little bit part of our response because
i
touched on the coronavirus we actually
developed a molded swab as well
the unique design of it it has two
channels
uh where it can collect liquid and
retain it
so having that capability will allow
uh multiple swaps to be dispensed
in one tube and we i'm gonna talk about
pooling
it is it so basically you can have
multiple swaps and you just shake it in
the tube
and you release everything out so it
retains
a good amount of sample and basically no
swap
you can take it out and just toss it you
know and no swap trapper would sample
that
basically you do not lose liquid you can
have more than one swap from different
individuals
and put it in one tube that would help
with the pulling aspect of things but
it is it was designed specifically to
address you know different types of
sample types
mainly nasal and fecal sample collection
lastly i want to say we are very proud
to be
[Music]
you know a us-made company everything we
make
or goes into our product is made in the
us
and we're very proud to to do that um
here you know basically i will i will
hand the rest of the presentation
um to my colleague dr julia
and this is here i get to the end of my
time
thank you and pleasure uh speaking to
you and and walking you through
maui dna technologies
thank you very much dr bassam so that
was a wonderful overview of maui dna
technologies and the work that they have
been doing
in covid and beyond throughout the
microbiome space
thank you so much sir so today i'm going
to walk you through planning to succeed
we're going to talk about issues and
problems in microbiome
studies and how you can put
standardization in place to help improve
your microbiome outcomes
a a quick uh overview of where we're
going to be we're going to start with
microbiome studies and challenges
we're going to give a overview of
validation that we have done at cosmos
id for the maui icewob microbiome
performance
of the system then we're going to drop
into
the study design and clinical trials and
issues and pitfalls that you sh
you will be facing in your clinical
trials and that you really want to be
putting concepts and and
ideas behind to really help improve
those logistical
um and process issues finally we're
going to talk about laboratory sources
of variability that can creep in
and how to help solve for those sources
of variability
we're going to talk finally about
analysis and how your microbiome
analysis and the tools that you use
can really help provide you with very
solid answers
and improve your total outcomes and then
we're going to move on to a q a session
at the end
so i know that this group here is very
well versed in microbiome and i don't
really have to convince you but for
those of you who are newer to the
microbiome space
i'm going to convince you that
microbiome is broadly indicated in
health and disease
there are hundreds of different studies
that are happening
in different disease indications on
different populations
and right now it's a great target for
diagnostic and therapeutic uses across
neurological
respiratory metabolic cancer autoimmune
there are many places right now where
we're really starting to have full-blown
clinical trials
investigating microbiome samples to give
outcomes for diseases and improvement in
patients lives every day
to help further put this home it's
increasingly a targeting clinical trial
so in 2012
there were five registered clinical
trials at clinicaltrials.gov in the
united states
with microbiome or microbiota as a
target endpoint
in 2016 there were 140 and this year in
2021 there are over 2 600 microbiome
trials on clinicaltrials.gov
that are registered and ongoing so we've
seen a great increase in interest
but with that great increase in interest
we have a great increase in
points of pain inside of our industry
so there are many different study
applications when it comes to microbiome
today's talk we're going to go ahead and
go with the top five here
observational microbiome studies of
clinical populations
also looking towards pre-clinical
development and how we can improve the
pain points that people have
in those types of trials and things to
think about in gcp compliant clinical
trials
when you're also looking at patient
stratification in larger
clinical trials and also finally
biomarker discovery
because it does often come back here
in microbiome studies that we um we go
through a clinical trial
and then biomarker discovery really does
come on um
afterwards and take that data and really
move through it
um so we want to go ahead and make sure
that we've got everything in place so
that it's
helpful throughout the life of an idea
for a concept for a therapeutic agent
so bottlenecks and metagenomics let's
get right in so
sample collection bias and ins that are
too low or the number of samples are too
low
to really take us to a great answer at
the end we're going to
talk about each one of these challenges
extraction biases library and
preparation or pcr biases
incomplete databases and also pipeline
and precision in the informatics and
analysis that are
supporting clinical trial analysis after
all the patient samples have been
brought in
so i'm going to move through now into
maui's iswob microbiome performance
and in a validation set that was
performed inside cosmos id
so just to give you a bit more
background from what bassam
was showing us the basics of sample
collection as they happen in the
microbiome space
when we really started moving into
microbiome we were freezing samples at
minus
80. um freezing samples at minus 80 is a
very
adequate and beautiful way to store your
samples
if you've got access to a minus 80 and
especially with covet and vaccine
chains happening minus 80s are
increasingly hard to come by
not everyone has one sitting in their
living room
so if your patients are taking samples
at home
and they're not able to move the samples
straight back to minus 80 storage you
have a cold chain problem
and a logistical issue and the
compliance of your clinical study
this isn't news to most people but for
some people it
it becomes something that confronts them
and it is is
something they really need to think
about before they move forward
collection kids have con come on to the
market over the years um starting
shortly after the human microbiome
project
with the dna genotech tube and here they
are displayed in relative size so the
the maui eye swab um
microbiome is here on the far left hand
side of these collection kits
we've got a relative size to the norgen
kit to the
um the zymo dna rna shield and then
finally to the dna genetic on the june
zep kit
so you can see that these these
different tubes take up quite a bit of
different
spaces they each have different positive
and negatives
but they also have a different
constituents that go inside of them as
as dr basam had
given us earlier that they do
contain irritant or toxic toxic
properties
those properties are wonderful for the
microbiome to be toxic near
toxic and irritant because we want to go
ahead and get those
samples stabilized in place in time
and we're able to put all four of these
different types of kits across
at room temperature storage so they all
do have that benefit
however the ice wob microbiome devices
is quite a bit smaller in
in footprint it's easier to ship for
that case
and it also is non-spillable technology
so
when the tube slips onto its side you
are not losing
the stabilization buffer out of the
collection kit
it also has the benefit the added
benefit that
over collection is not an issue those of
you who have done
fecal microbiome collections within the
laboratory or in central laboratories
have often seen this
that some clinical samples come in
overfilled
and they do not have the proper
stabilization to sample ratio
so the ice web technology does also
overcome this issue
next we're going to go into just the
bonuses so you've got uh iso microbiome
versus the others
non-toxic stabilization buffer and
inactivation of microbial activity
and finally it actually masks the foul
odor
that is resultant from stool soil
sludge and other less than ideal samples
we need the data out of those samples we
need the microbiome out of them but
often the ick factor can become at play
for patient compliance
so this one also helps reduce the smell
and you're not looking for any type of
cold chain storage
at the home of the participant taking a
home sample so this is quite a bonus
all right we're going to drop into data
and i'm going to be showing um
on the left hand side a frozen sample
of stool across time so we're starting
blue on the left hand side
to pink which is uh three days so blue
is zero days
pink is three days uh light green is day
seven
day fourteen is in orange day twenty one
is in yellow
day 40 is in dark green or like brain
part of me
and then we start over with the eye swab
technology so these are matched samples
across time they are samples that are
taking frozen and i swept microbiome and
really what we're showing here
is frozen versus ice swab microbiome at
the species level
in the heat maps here that across time
we have a very high level of concordance
between the species that are presented
an outcome of the microbiome analysis
and from eye swab to frozen we also have
a high concordance
this is physically visibly optically
available here and in the next slide
we're going to focus
on the alpha diversity metrics starting
with the shannon diversity
and so from day 0 to 3 to 7 14
21 and 40. on the left hand side i know
it's quite small so i'm going to walk
you through it we have
frozen and then maui technology just
looking at dna
and looking at the shannon diversity
metric across time
in both of those and when we compare
back
against one another at day seven we have
a pearson correlation
of 0.98 and at day 40 40 days after
collection in room temperature storage
we maintain a pearson correlation 0.94
so high correlation across time on
the right hand side of the slide we have
a replicate in rna
in the rna space so from day 0 through
day
21 the study did not go all the way up
to day 40 went out to day 21
we also maintain a high concordance
between
the frozen samples and the maui samples
over time
now just to say a little further when
you go into child diversity or other
diversity metrics we see quite the same
story
we have high concordance across time day
to day and over a time
course so the maui products
here the islab microbiome was taken
through
metagenomic sequencing and i did forget
to mention earlier that
it was the first of the stabilization
kits in the microbiome space
that have validation completed in the
metagenomic space in
in wgs as opposed to 16f or simply
looking at qpcr for dna itself
so not only are we looking at
stabilization we're really looking at
microbiome effects
over time now i'm going to
move forward with study design and
clinical trials
so we're going to talk about end-to-end
metagenomic solutions
and end in metagenomic problems so we're
going to talk about study design and
sample collection
move through to optimizing sample
preparation
talking about how clia and gcp
sequencing in a laboratory really
uphold the quality and what that quality
means to you
then we're going to move forward to
strain level functional and
bioinformatics interpretation and
publication
for an end-to-end solution that can
really support your microbiome trial
all right so pre laboratory bottlenecks
those are the things that are going to
get you
if you're not thinking about them before
you're moving into the laboratory for
for um actual extraction and sequencing
now we've talked about what happens with
the basics of sample collection
and whether you need to freeze or you
need to have a room temperature
stabilization as you move forward but
i'd also like to remind you
that the collection the sample
collection methodology
can have a major impact so instructions
um
should be provided with any collection
that you're sending home with a patient
even though you typically have a nurse
or a clinical practitioner
walking through what that collection is
going to look like having
simple instructions as they get home and
begin to
actually take those samples is a huge
important step so that it's
it's happening as homogeneously as
possible across your entire study
next is storage conditions so if we've
got room temperature storage
we're doing great for normal or normal
days normal timelines
but we also have to worry about the
shipping and courier selection
so is it better to freeze and ship many
samples together from a centralized site
is it better to box each one up and send
it individually through the mail
how exactly is that box going to look dr
bassam
had indicated that maui offers a
a white box that surrounds in its usps
or ups or fedex
appropriate cosmos id also offers the
same
type of service around different types
of kits so we can do a custom kit
assembly to really take
both your collection methodology the
sample collections and the shipping and
courier selection
into account and then finally at the
bottom we have the limb system for
sample accessioning
you want to make sure that you're not
riding on a tube
no patient has to ride on a tube they're
assigned a tube
it's got a barcode they are going to
return that barcode it's going to fit
seamlessly into a system
it's going to move forward for
processing and then it is going
lickety-split
all the way through exactly what it's
supposed to do we have no problems with
identity
we have no problems with smudged or
smeared handwriting
and in some patient populations
especially those patient populations
that are more vulnerable
younger or may have shaking hands due to
their disease to
the disease indication we want to make
sure that they have the most seamless
easy process possible
now moving away from patients and into
our own
study designs i'd like to talk to you
about the number
of samples that you're putting into your
clinical trials
here i have pulled an image from a
gastroenterology paper that did a really
beautiful
job of really explaining what effect
size versus total sample size looked at
there's a bar in the tupper uh top upper
part of the
graph that is an 80 chance of being able
to see a pattern
with a different effect size so you've
got a an effect size
of 0.55 an fx size of 0.82 and an effect
size of 1.09
so an effect size of 0.55 is a pretty
minimal pattern
in in the data so we've we've got a
species
we've got a taxonomy we've got a
function that is different between
group a and group b and it's
it's easier to find or it's harder to
find depending on the effect size a
larger effect size is an easier pattern
to find
and a lower effect size is a much more
difficult pattern to find
whether that's because those organisms
are not
high level in the sequencing or not so
along the bottom of the graph we have
the total sample size and it starts at
20
and 20 per sample so if you're looking
at group a
and group b you need 20 of each to be
able to see
an effect um of 0.5
uh 5.82 or 1.09
um as you go higher and higher so of
course if we've got a higher effect size
we can use a lower number of samples
if you get around 40 samples per group
you're 80 percent likely to see that
effect if that effect is present in the
population
if you have very minimal effect if
you've got something that's only
slightly attenuating the microbiome so
it's something that's not a really
profound disease or an antibiotic
exposure
we really need to talk about having much
larger sample sizes
and this is true throughout clinical
trials throughout indications
throughout statistical means and
throughout laboratory testing
it is universally true we've really got
to think about what those effect sizes
are
often this does take pilot data and we
can discuss with you what the
indications are there
if you're starting out fresh and you're
looking at a biomarker discovery trial
you may be left with what you're able to
get but you always want to fight for
those larger group sizes
so that even less profound effects are
very easily
found in your microbiome analysis
all right we're going to slip into
sources of variability that are
within the laboratory and the things you
should really think about
and push for with laboratory
processing of microbiome samples
the first thing we're really going to
talk about is dna extraction
and really thinking about and
considering your extraction type for
different sample types
today i'm talking primarily about stool
but this can talk
this can go into vaginal samples skin
samples
oral samples whether they're saliva or
plaque tongue scrapings
in different areas of the microbiome in
different body
sites on a human being or on a mouse
model in pre-clinical studies
we have very different biomass levels
and very different organisms
present and we truly want to make sure
that we're considering the physical
characteristics of those microbes
when we begin to try to lyse them open
and get full extracted dna from them
so this particular slide is biological
representativeness
under the average coverage so those are
just different organisms
that were looked at with four different
methods
for extraction so physical bead beading
enzymatic only chemical only and then a
hybrid
enzymatic and bead beading so both
physical
chemical and how
physical can definitely get you
a good extraction but in some cases it
can over shear
easy easily lysed organisms hybrid
definitely one out in this study but
let's go over enzymatic and chemical can
also
miss things so if you're not really
getting that physical and
comparable enzymatic so that you're
really doing a one-two punch to the
microbial cells uh breaking open each
one
but not so tough that we're actually
losing dna of those easily lysed
organisms
these four orange spheres around the
purple points
actually show that in this particular
study the chemical lysis which was
a phenyl chloroform c tab chemical lysis
completely missed four organisms that we
know were present in the market
community that was there
so i'm going to go ahead and move
forward make sure that you're
truly considering overcoming
differential lysis depending on the
sample type that you're studying
further into sample type sequencing
depth can be
highly impacted by the
body site that you're looking at the
biomass that's within the samples
and the organism or pattern that you're
looking for
so sequencing depth really you do not
have to sequence as deeply to get a
true representative sample of a skin
microbiome
than you would from an oral cavity than
you would from a feces sample
there at the bottom so we're at the top
we have skin and vaginal samples
the obelisk in the middle is the oral
cavity different sites in the oral
cavity
down at the bottom we have feces and
digesta and
feces and digestive must be sequenced
much more deeply
for a deep dive into all of the
different organisms that are present
however this also depends on the
hypothesis that you're trying to
answer to so if you're trying to
discover novel organisms you must
sequence much more deeply
than if you're doing a study where your
hypothesis is detection
something suspected or known in the
literature versus whether you are
looking at surveillance of
known so if you know there's a pattern
you've done a prior study
you know exactly where your effect size
is and exactly how profound that effect
is on your target population
but now you're doing the phase three
clinical trial you do not have to
sequence as deeply you can actually
really hone in on where
where and what depth you need to
sequence so
um i'm going to go one slide further
and show you that deep versus moderate
we have high reproducibility
so this is on the left deep metagenomic
sequencing
and is a total average sequencing depth
of 90 million reads
on the right hand side we have moderate
depth sequencing and a total of 9
million
average rates so on the left 90 million
on the right
9 million so a 10 fold increase in
sequencing and we maintain
a very good representation in moderate
sequencing
if we're looking for something very
specific and very minor
going deep can really show us those
those organisms that are much harder to
find
much more needle in a haystack and we
can really pull them out
but a lot of times moderate sequencing
really does show us exactly what we're
looking for
and the beautiful thing about this is is
that if you do a pilot study
on deep sequencing and you move back to
moderate we maintain
a 96 correlation between the two data
sets
so they're extremely similar in outcome
now i've often been asked is
16 of sequencing or metagenomic
sequencing bad
the answer here is we're scientists so
it always depends
amplicon sequencing can answer some very
specific
questions it does have caveats
in that genus level ids are about the
best thing you're going to be able to
get in most cases
there are some cases where people find
species level ids but never really
subspecies level ids in 16s
but that's really not the typical normal
identifier across
an entire study in amplicon 16 of
sequencing
stenos sequencing is also suitable for
low biomass samples
and samples with very high host
contamination like biopsy samples
[Music]
so this tool is very very well suited to
some types of hypotheses
shallow shotgun metagenomics that's
looking at a very low level
of metagenomic sequencing allows you to
look
at genus level species level strain
level
multi-kingdom ids absolutely and has a
lower false positive rate than 16s or
amplicon sequencing however
very low biomass samples are not always
great for shallow shotgun sequencing
and there are some other functional and
antimicrobial resistance virulence
factors
that are much harder to find with very
shallow shotgun metagenomics
deep shotgun metagenomics as you see
here does each and every one of these
things
and cosmos id is able to offer them at
price points that will really make you
look
but between amplicon sequencing and deep
shock of metagenomics as the technology
has evolved
um we're really at a cost of science
where we can really give and take
depending on exactly what the hypothesis
is and exactly what sample types we're
looking at to make the most informed
scientific discussion
happen so is it good or bad
it really depends on your hypothesis in
some cases it's not really going to suit
in other cases it's going to work
beautifully
all right so let's talk about
standardization and controls
you're a scientist and one of my
advisors in grad school said that you're
two best friends with
scientists or you're negative and
positive controls i sincerely hope my
best friends never heard me say that out
loud
but so negative impulsive control should
be in every experiment that's ever run
and we should always have them going we
also offer
internal spiking controls and these
different controls really look at
different parts
of the processing because microbiome
sequencing
is not a one and done
laboratory process you're not just
putting a stool sample straight onto the
sequencer there there are several up
front steps that we've discussed whether
that's
dna extraction or library preparation
pcr cycles
so you want to make sure that your
negative controls and your positive
controls are added at different parts
of these assays to adequately observe
where variability has happened across
studies and from inter-study variability
also so
inside the study if you've got a very
large number of samples you're really
going to be watching those negative
controls and positive controls as
they're added to
your sample collections um we do suggest
that actual buffer controls are added
anytime there's a buffer that you're
bringing into a study
that you're wedding with or any type of
additive that you're using in
a drug application that you go ahead and
make sure that you've got those negative
and positive controls
with your organisms organisms of
interest where that is present
so when it gets to the laboratory we add
negative and positive controls again
to examine extraction biases so we have
mock communities
and then dna samples prior extracted dna
or mock community dna
of known compositions that are inserted
during library preparation
and those are really allow us to follow
through and confirm
that everything is working all of our
tools are working as designed
we're seeing exactly what we're expo
we're supposed to see
that you can be assured that we've got a
reproducible pipeline
and then finally internal spiking
controls um some odd cases require
that we add an internal spiking control
to really assure ourselves
something like low biomass is actually
being processed correctly even though
some answers will be no within the
laboratory
and i always have to put this slide in
because i have quality in my title
um then the benefits of qa so quality
assurance
are many but the biggest and best that
really
apply to us inside us in the science uh
of microbiome studies
are that we have reproducibility and
complete comp
compliance the availability of records
so quality
really supports clinical studies by
making sure that everyone in the
laboratory is
well trained assured that their their
instrumentation is doing it exactly what
it's supposed to do
that what they're doing today and four
fridays from now is exactly the same
method
that technician a and technician b are
right on par with one another
so we get that reproducibility through
standardized
de-risk procedures and validated methods
and then the compliance end of that is
really just making sure records of what
we did
are present and available to ourselves
and to the fda should they ever come
looking
and that is quality in a nutshell making
sure we did things correctly and then we
got credit for it by making sure those
records are
in place and ready anytime anyone needs
them
all right now finally we're going to
talk about analysis
in your microbiome study so
cosmos id has an unrivaled
bioinformatics pipeline
um and i don't have to tell you um this
genome biology article that i'm signing
out to here
did a very deep dive of different
bioinformatics
software that are available in the
metagenomic ngs space
and cosmos id if you see here the
red bars are f1 which is basically a
harmonic mean of recall and precision
so that's an overall metric of how well
samples were related to taxonomy within
an ngs sample higher is better on this
graph 100
is the most ideal cosmos id's tools got
extremely close to 100 percent
um different available software suites
are also on this graphic um but i'd like
to point out
that cosmos id really has a one-two
punch of quality here
because it's not just the ability to
assign taxonomy
it's also the algorithm underlying that
assignment so
we have a well-curated industry-leading
database
that is being handled by our scientists
on an ongoing basis
to improve taxonomic resolution but
truly it's the algorithm underlying that
really takes
those assignments and takes them into
individual buckets and tells you exactly
what that strain or that substrate
is so really getting down to the strain
level
on your microbiome calls
here in the smaller print if you're
squinting so we have megan
filosoft several different iterations
and flaggings to see if they could get
better precision or recall out of
those different tools and nothing quite
stood up to the in-house
binge marking that happened so this is a
subspecies resolution if you'd like to
see it higher level at the species
resolution
this genome biology article also goes
really deep into how that's happening
so we have the world's largest curated
database we have machine learning
filters that are really helping assign
those bins so that we really assign
correctly
we assign with precision to make sure
we're able to tell
everything apart and we've got 50 plus
publications i think this is upwards of
60 at this point this year
really showing that that's useful in
different spaces
and again since you don't have to take
my word for it even more you don't
have to take my word for it cosmos id
has been independently validated
by third party validation so different
groups have released
samples to cosmos id and put them
through the cosmos id software
this includes the the yanson mosaic
challenge
that happened very recently and then
two precision fda challenges one on
pathogen detection and the other on bio
threat challenges
so bioterroristic or bio threat strains
they were put into
samples and and moved to the cosmos id
software
pathogen detection challenges that were
put through the cosmos id software and
in each case cosmos id
came out the winner the top hit possible
in those detection challenges so
third-party validation right there
all right and to top it off not only do
we have
one of the world's best databases we
have the world's best way to figure out
which
species and subspecies and strains are
in your your samples
we also have a usually user-friendly
data access so
cloud-based application that will take
your big
microbiome data and take it down into a
comparative analysis you can do in your
yoga pants at home during the pandemic
so really and truly the easiest most
comprehensive database
the best algorithm to determine what it
is and then
you can do it from the comfort of your
own desk or your own home and really
start getting deep into the data to
really take your questions and
hypothesis
through to the next level
right that's not to say that custom
bioinformatics and support are not
present
um but they absolutely are through
cosmos id so we can give you functional
metagenomic and gene binding metadata
based microbiome analyses
and custom databases are basically on
demand
depending on what strain you're looking
at and if you've got a proprietary
strain in your microbiome study
definitely something worth considering
throughout your study to make sure that
your
exquisite strain that no one else has is
really being
checked against the microbiome that you
study
that you're performing all right so
we've walked through
end and metagenomic problems with indian
metagenomic solutions from study design
and sample collection
optimized sample preparation in the
laboratory
quality enforced sequencing strain level
and functional bioinformatics and
finally we've briefly touched on
interpretation and publication
i'd like to thank you all for coming on
this microbiome journey with me and
talking about all of the pain points
and the possible ways that you can
really get at answers
for your pain points i'd be happy to
take questions at this point and i'm
going to release it to alexis
to go ahead and take us into the qa
thank you dr julia and dr bassam for
your informative presentation
we are now going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question tab
excuse me
on the ask a question tab on the far
left of your screen and we are going to
answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started it looks like our
first question
is going to be for dr bassam
what do you mean when you say i swab
microbiome
is non-toxic
that's an excellent question so
basically the majority of
we like to call it stabilizer by a
stabilization buffer rather than
preservatives the majority of uh
the stabilization room temperature
stabilizat preservatives in the market
has guanidium thiocyanate or any of
those
you know aggressive salts as well as
potentially alcohol or organic solvents
maybe formaldehyde
our products our stabilizer does not
have any of those
and all the components are actually uh
being sourced out from or pre-approved
fda
actually material so
for consume for human consumption
so this is this is what's what it is so
it's
basically um very safe um
you know it goes into your touches your
skin it just like just wash it
does nothing uh you're not worried if it
stays
for a long period of time just literally
wash it with water
um and that's basically it is um you
know
sum it up doesn't have any of those uh
or surfactants
any guanidium tyrosine any surfactants
any any of those
organic solvents
great thank you so much dr bassam for
that clarification
um moving on to our next question dr
julia it looks like this one is going to
be for you
could you describe the cosmos id quality
system for clinical trials
absolutely alexis so cosmos id
in our clinical trials we have a quality
management system or a qms that supports
them
and that includes both validated and
monitored equipment
and software trained and qualified
personnel with records of training
approved suppliers with validated
reagents
inventory controls on anything that
comes into the laboratory and is used on
the study
and for all samples that come within the
laboratory
recording your reporting on all
non-conformances and root cause analysis
that supports those
recording and reporting and then records
of all processing
those are really the tenants of a
quality management system that take us
through
supporting a clinical trial having full
records and full traceability and
tractability
for every sample that moves from the
entry into the laboratory
through exit um through sequencing
thank you dr julia dr bassam we're going
to come back over to you for our next
one
can you explain how nexswob can be
better than standard swabs at pulling
and concentrating samples absolutely
so uh as you know current swaps is
mostly flocked or has like fibers so
when you're gonna pull those swaps you
end up
using like a 50 ml conical most you know
a lot of us
we see the ginkgo approach or or the
broad
institute approach where they process
samples in 50 ml centrifuge
tubes with multiple swap center with ton
of
reagents due to lice and process
which is really you know
a large you know a large amount of
chemicals added
with neck swab we
substitute the fibers with those two
channels
that we have in the middle of the swab
head so literally you can collect
actually a defined volume because they
can
collect so much on those and
and because of that a lot of
different different molded swap or 3d
printed swaps
structures have the capability of
collecting and
and basically you literally have to uh
process the sample right away it's the
amount of material is not
optimal for uh especially corona virus
testing
if we take that where here you have you
collect enough
liquid in those uh in those two channels
if i would call them correctly and
basically you just flick it on the t
in the tube with any stabilization
buffer or our
we recommend using eye swap of course
and you just flick it and you take it
out so because there is no fibers
and you're releasing everything on the
swab at the molded swap
so you can actually use another swap
somebody else
and do the same thing and you end up
with
a sample that has uh offers
stabilized and have all those different
swaps
content in there without these losing
any liquid
or adding more liquid to it
thank you so much dr bassam and as we're
looking for our next question i just
want to remind our audience
um any of your questions that we are
unable to get to today we will be
following up or
excuse me our speakers will be following
up via email with the answers to your
questions so
on to our next one um dr julia we'll go
back to you
can i access a trial of the cosmos id
bioinformatics
absolutely so if you go to cosmos id.com
the website that we're showing here you
can access and register for a free
trial of our application and actually
kick the tires on it and take it through
a human microbiome project data set and
if you reach out to us we can get you in
touch with our business development team
that can actually really sit with you
and talk to you about your particular
sample type
in a lot of cases they can show you data
sets that we've analyzed that are
completely de-identified
but you can see the sample type and how
it behaves on the cosmos id app
and really just walk all the way through
those comparative analyses
the different levels of taxonomic
assignment and really look at all of the
graphical
interfaces that you're able to really
visualize your data with
because after all the human eye and the
brain are much better
at visual data interpretation and it
really takes you to a place where you
can take
different hypotheses forward and ask
different questions of the data
thank you dr julia um how about
our next question okay here's here's a
good one
if i wanted to build a direct to
consumer microbiome product
would you be able to help me get it off
the ground
oh absolutely so we have done this for
different collaborator clients in the
past
we have everything available from
branded boxing
different types of kit components
depending on the market
that you're targeting um the different
parts of the world that you're in the
regulatory environment
and we can help you really go from soup
to nuts on what does the collection look
like
getting it out there and with your
distribution network
and then really taking it to the end and
taking you through an analysis and a
reporting
that's compliant and really looking for
what you're trying to do
so we are absolutely able to help get
direct to consumer microbiomes off the
ground
thank you dr julia so um
how about okay dr bassam let's go back
over to you
what type of samples is i swab
microbiome compatible with
we actually optimized it to be like the
universal microbial sample collection so
you could use
of course we've shown fecal samples oral
vaginal vaginal skin and basically any
material you could use swab with to use
the
swab to collect with soy of course
it has been used is it it has been ios
and being used in
in actually looking at uh in
in agriculture looking at certain
collecting samples from
grapevines for you know checking
from different types of fungi and
diseases so um
so basically any sample um environmental
sample
um that uses the swap also we actually
uh offer it in terms of uh
without using a swap let's say if you
want to stabilize a sludge
or wastewater um we have uh
two customers using it and that mana
without using the eye swap technology
which is the squeegee
so we can we give them pre-filled tubes
to use it
and stabilize their waste water so
basically you know any microbial sample
great thank you so much it looks like we
have time for maybe one or two more
questions
for today our next one for stool samples
do you recommend shallow shotgun or 16s
oh as i said earlier it will depend on
your hypothesis but for the most part
we've really
shown and the literature truly supports
the shallow shotgun or even
moderate sequencing depth is far more
beneficial to hypotheses surrounding
stool studies
so that you're really capturing the less
high effect sizes so if you've got a
very minor effect or something that's
that's a harder pattern to find you want
to make sure that you've got a a larger
data set around it the shallow
shotgunning
or moderate shotgun are definitely the
way to go with stool samples
because of the complexity of the sample
and the variability from person to
person
we definitely want to be there as
opposed to in in 16s
thank you so much dr julia and we want
to thank
dr julia and dr bassam for their time
today
do you have any final comments for our
audience uh dr bassam we'll go ahead and
start with you
um not really so i would i would
sum it up i would say no you know it is
very important to stabilize samples and
to have keep it at the status quo
you know we always work on the concept
of junk and junk out
so sample collection has been overlooked
for for many many years and now
uh there is more focus on it and with
the pandemic coming in
we had so much issues with with the
supply chain
uh one of which is coaching cold chain
transport
ice packs were in back order so having
sample collection that is non-toxic and
can stabilize samples at the point of
collection to processing
enable enable uh enable research to move
forward
enable our understanding of human health
and so at a global level and when i say
global level
basically you know it's very important
for the chemistry to work with any
extraction chemistry out there not
everybody has a zymer extraction kit
and basically you know not everybody has
a mag track not
everybody has you know a power soil so
or access to it so whatever chemistry
that is used for microbial analysis
should not be limited to the sample
collection december collection should be
universal in that perspective so
and this is what we did we actually
even pushed the envelope further where
we're trying to remove text
the need for rna extraction where it is
i swap microbiome el extraction list
for uh for coronavirus testing molecular
coronavirus testing
so um all these things that you know uh
are very important i go back and sum it
up saying
sample collection is is very critical
for any successful outcome
and i would recommend you choose wisely
and look
closely and that's about it
thank you dr bassam dr julia do you have
any closing comments for us
i would very much like to thank the
audience for sticking with us
this late in the afternoon for those of
you after lunch it's been lovely
speaking with you and if you'd like to
continue the conversation
please reach either dr basama myself
through the websites
below or the email addresses we're
currently presenting
thank you so much for your time
thank you again dr julia and dr bassam
for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank levers and our
sponsor
maui dna technologies for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us and for their
interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
so please keep those questions coming in
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time stay safe stay healthy
bye bye everyone